- You wanna see it kicking
back in normal conditions
and you wanna test it in
not-so-normal conditions
until that's not kickback,
you wanna give it all
of the edge cases so it
know what's going on.
- [Destin] Why are you
smiling, why are you smiling?
(laughing)
- I think we should test the edge cases.
- I normally say, "Hey, it's me Destin,
"welcome back to Smarter Every Day,"
but there's nothin' smart about this.
So here's the deal, this is a rocket saw
and I wanna say I'm sorry
but I'm totally not.
Here's the deal, here's how we got here.
So in the last video, we explained
how we had incorporated machine learning
into power tools in order to keep them
from hurting you, right?
So the way you work with a
machine learning algorithm
is you get a really big fancy computer
and you start to sort events out
like data collection events.
In our case, normal use of a saw
so we see like a normal thing
that happens with a saw,
we put it in the normal bucket, right?
But as we see these
things that are dangerous,
we would put those over
here in the dangerous pile
and if you do this enough,
eventually the computer
can sort between dangerous
events and normal events.
You can't test everything in the world,
okay so you come up with all
these really weird things
and you do your best to like sort 'em out
but eventually you get to the edge cases
and you have to make a decision
like as a human, where do these things go?
One of those things we thought
about was a rocket saw.
Obviously the rocket saw's gonna go
in the danger pile and
we're not actually gonna
collect data on this shot but we thought
about a rocket saw and once you realize
you're smart enough to make a rocket saw--
So we got a rocket powered saw
and we're gonna see what happens.
I think it's just gonna stop back there.
I don't think it's gonna
make it this far, do you?
- [Man] Yeah, no bets buddy.
- [Destin] Four rockets,
we got two Fs and two Ds.
- If only we had five.
- [Destin] If only we had fire.
And you've got it all wired
up, ready to go, right?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Destin] This GoPro
lookin' back at the blade
is gonna be nice.
Like the GoPro should see
the engagement of the teeth
and stuff, this is so dumb, I love it.
(saw running)
I think it makes--
(laughing)
Alright, you're tall, you
gotta turn that beast on.
So it's ready to fire, right?
You've got the thing wired up, right?
- Right.
- Okay.
This is one of the more noble things
I've ever done in my life.
Now would be an excellent time
to make a prediction on what you think
this thing is gonna do to the wood.
Also, the very first video I ever uploaded
to this channel, called, "How to Light
"a Bonfire with Rockets," cringe-worthy.
It's like the first video ever made.
It also involves shooting a rocket
from this exact same tree.
(beeping)
(saw running)
Alright, lemme go arm
the high-speed camera.
- [Man] Oh my god.
(laughing)
(saw running)
Three, two, holy crap, one.
(rocket whizzing)
One!
(laughing)
What happened?
Holy crap.
- [Destin] Get the GoPro
before it catches on fire.
- [Man] If it's still there.
- [Destin] Oh, it's still there.
- [Man] Is it still there?
- Oh!
(laughing)
Totally survived.
- [Man] It bounced up.
- [Destin] Yeah I don't even
think, like it didn't even try.
It didn't even try.
- [Man] It just rolled on it.
- [Man 2] We got it man.
- [Destin] Did we, dude?
We totally did, oh!
(laughing)
(slow motion rocket whizzing)
That's a thing you can do with friends.
- [Man] On a Friday night.
- Who needs drugs when
you can do stuff like this, right?
Let's zoom in closer
and see if the saw blade
does what you thought it would do.
(laughing)
Oh my goodness, my heart.
Oh it just dinged the screen?
Who cares, did you see
what we just did with that?
(laughing)
This episode of Smarter Every Day
is sponsored by Casper Mattress
and Prince Rupert and I
are going to unbox a
Casper Mattress for you.
No, come here.
(meowing)
This mattress is called The Wave.
The Wave is designed
specifically for the needs
of side sleepers like my wife and I.
The whole deal here is that it has
a perforated breathable memory foam
to keep your spine
aligned during the night
and keep you cool because it's breathable.
As you press on something,
the amount of squish
is a function of the
elasticity of the material.
The fancy thing they've done with The Wave
is they've varied the elasticity
from the head to the foot of the bed
so you get more elasticity
around the shoulder areas
cause most people's shoulders
are wider than their hips
so it aligns your spine as you sleep
on your side which is a big stinkin' deal
because my wife is a side sleeper.
First two nights with Casper
Wave, what do you think?
- I like it, I like it.
Am I supposed to look at the camera
or am I supposed to look at you?
- [Destin] Does it matter?
You wanted a side sleepin' mattress,
does it do what you need?
- I did want one, it does
what I need, absolutely.
- All Wave purchases come with a free
in-home set-up and a hundred night trial.
If you don't like it, let 'em know,
they'll come get it, no questions asked.
Their pillows are also awesome by the way,
we've got the soft layer on the outside
and a firm layer on the inside
so each side of the pillow feels like
the cool side of the pillow.
They didn't ask me to
talk about the pillows,
I asked them if I could
talk about their pillows.
You can get 50 dollars off a core mattress
or a hundred dollars off The Wave mattress
which is ideal for side sleeping
if you go to Casper.com/smarter
use the promo code smarter at checkout,
you're gonna get a better night's sleep,
they have engineers workin' on this stuff.
You're still here which
means you understand.
We're both winnin' here, my whole life
led up to this moment
to make the rocket saw.
Your whole life led up
to watching this video,
we're all winners.
Thanks.
There was a smart reason that
we got to that point, I promise.
- I think we yelled, "For
science!" several times.
- Yeah, that's how that works.
Alright, well, you're
getting smarter every day.
Have a good one, thanks for watchin'.